tirez pas retourné
at on
écoutez moi rien ni personne ne peut
ouvrir cette porte depuis des étages
n'ya rien d'impossible
quand on est suffisamment motivé
[Musique]
écoute cousin tu vas me ramener zhao est
ce qu'ils gardent au chaud derrière ses
portes
où je me lance la fille du toit de cette
tour de merde
cette banque ça fait dix ans que j'ai
pas touché normale après ce qui s'est
passé cette nuit là
j'ai comme qui dirait rengaine aimons
colts mais sans ce coup du sort vous
allez vous en sortir
je n'aurais jamais connu sahara j'aurais
jamais eu des enfants papa rim qui a pas
une qui jetait d'intérêt monsieur hire
vous êtes la toute première famille que
nous accueillons dans la partie
résidentielle the pearl à l'issue de
votre audit de sécurité
que pensez vous de la tour de pearl et
la structure ultra haute la plus
sophistiqués au monde
c'est une prouesse technologique mais
c'est difficile de prévoir ce qui
arriverait en cas de problème
[Musique]
salut les gars
que ça brûle le 96e est en feu sarah
écoute moi le feu va progresser vous
devez monter ne vous arrêtez pas ne vous
tournez pas ok [ __ ] au won on
attendait ma famille est à l'intérieur
tournez-vous
surtout regarde pas en bas
c'était pas mal hein
je me suis jetée d'une crue
voilà l'homme que nous cherchions cette
tour protège quelque chose que je veux
et tu va me rapporter rien n'était
impossible quand on est motivé
non
ensemble on a peur
c'est normal d'avoir peur
pour être courageux avant il faut avoir
un petit peu peur
on doit sortir de cette tour tu veux
bien être courageux pour moi ouais pas
paniquer mois
[Musique]
tu te mets tout